depuis les annonces on arrive sur une
semaine qui est quand même bien plus les
verts en termes de réservations ils sont
inquiets pendu aux lèvres du
gouvernement sur de possibles nouvelles
mesures liées à la crise sanitaire les
restaurateurs des yvelines ne savent pas
vraiment à quoi s'attendre
un tant soit peu rassurés du maintien de
l'ouverture de leurs voisins de paris et
de la petite couronne la grande couronne
n'en reste pas moins aux aguets c'est le
cas à voisins le bretonneux
le nouveau protocole ne nous concerne
pas pour l'instant directement il ya des
risques qu'un jour ça descendre jusqu'à
nous donc l'attrait un petit peu plus
compliqué il a un petit peu plus
contraignant
ce qui m'inquiète le plus entre nous
c'est que on a un métier normalement de
convialité d'accueil de chaleur et
qu'aujourd'hui on met beaucoup de
distance et ça c'est un petit peu un
crève coeur pour nous restaurateurs car
c'est un lieu de rassemblement des
changes normalement à juziers dans le
nord des yvelines en plus de la crainte
de la fermeture c'est aussi la perte de
clientèle qui préoccupent les
professionnels de la restauration
on leur impose déjà pas mal de
protocoles et si en plus il ya encore et
encore et encore d'autres protocoles à
mettre en place
je pense que les gens finiront par plus
sortir du tout cas à l'heure actuelle le
couple ne veut pas perdre espoir et
continue d'assurer le service
c'est de garder le contact avec les
clients qui nous restent et qui sont
courageux a toujours sortir à devoir
nous soutenir parce que la plupart qui
viennent ils sont commis dans une
démarche de soutien
un soutien que le couple de
restaurateurs de jausiers aimerait aussi
obtenir de la part de leur assureur ils
ont rejoint le collectif resto ensemble
pour demander un dédommagement pour la
perte d'exploitation durant le
confinement
environ 90 milles euros encore un autre
sujet d'inquiétude